I'm joined Now by Maran bishara Al
jair's senior political analyst good to
have you with us so we want to talk a
little bit Maran about what the strategy
will be going forward especially in
light of the statements we heard from
the US Deputy ambassador to the United
Nations where he basically said no
ceasefire that would leave Hamas
standing or Hamas in power what does
that mean unending open-ended War yeah I
think Israel is ready for an open-ended
War it will come under pressure by the
United States it will come under
economic pressure because there is a
cost to this war but fortunately the
United States is providing a diplomatic
uh immunity and it's providing for the
time being perhaps $4 billion dollar to
cover up for the War uh costs thus far
but what if time proves what many
military strategists are warning that
the goal of completely eradicating Hamas
is simply not going to happen and after
two months it certainly hasn't happened
well we won't know right I mean look at
uh look how it all started it all
started by uh both Netanyahu and Biden
comparing Hamas to Isis and to
Al-Qaeda the war against alqaeda has
gone on for 20 years the war against
Terror has gone on for that much and
it's still continuing the war against
Iraq one for 10 years I think Israel
considers its war against the
Palestinians even more important than
America's war against Afghanistan Iraq
it considered it an existential War I'll
go further than
that I tell you I think Israel as an
entity as a project it feels more at
ease during war than it does during
peace time or so-called peace process
time you know from
1991 for 12 dozen years or so Israel
changed six or seven governments during
the peace process time from Shamir to
Rabin to to Paris to Netanyahu to Barack
to Shon to Almer it changed seven Prime
Ministers right and then when it stopped
with the peace process and K Netanyahu
we had one prime minister for 13 years
in fact it's more stable Israel is more
stable when it's not in a peace in a
peace time or peace process time it does
not have an issue with being a state at
War because since its creation it's been
a state at War it's a Garrison State so
the military establishment and the far
right and the Fanatics and the fascists
and the Israeli government all of them
feed on violence and they would want to
have a state of War so can they can
destroy Gaza and they can reoccupy the
West Bank and kick out the Palestinian
Authority and establish more and more
settlements double triple the
settlements there and try to squeeze out
the Palestinians to what extent would
the US go along with that is that sort
of scenario in US interests what do we
know if Biden is going to be there you
know in a year time we don't know what
we know is that he boxed himself in
behind Netanyahu he begged Netanyahu and
the Israeli government to buy him some
time meaning just give him something
like humanitarian this that and the
other thing agree with him on the
two-state idea anything that he can s to
the rest of the world so he can keep
shielding Israel but they won't give him
anything and still he's boxing himself
against behind Netanyahu and that's what
explains the vote yesterday so for the
time being the United States understands
that this kind of a Warfare as they fed
against Al-Qaeda and Afghanistan took 20
years if Israel is going to take 20
months then let it be 20 months I think
is for the time being Israel considers
what it does it must do and the world
can say whatever it wants okay but this
is not the preow days in terms of the
global pet of power so coming back to
the battlefield the longer that this can
drag out does it risk dragging in more
countries into this conflict or do you
see that sort of scenario that people
were talking about in the first weeks
after this that that's not so likely
anymore for the time being what we see
is that Iran is distancing itself from
the scenario of war and we see the
United States remains with its
deployment of aircraft carriers and
nuclear submarines and still pushing and
pumping arms to Israel so Israel is
continuing with the war and I think in
so many ways Israel as I said needs the
war for the time being in order to
establish a number of its own red lines
right including settlements ethnic
cleansing and so on so forth so I think
it doesn't have much of a problem with
that even regionally yes America warns
that on the long term it will start
losing allies or potential allies that
normalized relations with Israel but for
the time being we're not saying that now
we are now for the timeing we're talking
about months perhaps one months two more
months of the land Invasion and then the
war could change to something else
perhaps something that looks like more
of
incursions uh security zones and
squeezing the Palestinians out slowly
but surely I think that kind of a I'm
not going to call it low intensity
Warfare but whatever the next stage of
the war is going to be Israel is going
to decide and it's going to go by it and
it doesn't care what the rest of the
world says if Trump steps in in November
or January 2025 that they going to have
another Ally in the White House that
will will support them and support what
they need to do be a whole different
ball game so much more to talk about but
we're got to leave it here for now
perhaps L thanks so much Maran bishara